Almost eight years ago,
Baiju Bhatt and I founded Robinhood.
We believed then as we do now
that the financial system should be built
to work for everyone,
not just a select few.
It's really simple,
just press three buttons
and then you already got the
amount of crypto that you want.
Just about any stock I've wanted,
I've been able to grab
and it's been pretty easy to use
and I've felt pretty safe.
Robinhood is a stock trading application
that's really popular among
the younger investing crowd.
So, mainly Gen Zers and Millennials
and one of the reasons why
it is so popular among them
is because of its design.
Just from a design angle,
if you open Robinhood's app
and you open the other apps for Schwab
or TD Ameritrade or E*TRADE,
you can tell that they look different.
Trying to convince investors
that trading is simple and easy
is not new to Robinhood.
Robinhood's just been more successful
at making it simple and easy.
Robinhood's design
enables users to sign up
and start trading within
a matter of minutes.
Its colorful, easy-to-use interface
resembles something more
at home in Silicon Valley
than Wall Street.
Robinhood's mission has always been
to democratize finance.
And so, when they set
out to build their app,
what they wanted to do was to
remove any barriers of entry
that have existed for people
who've wanted to invest
in the stock market,
but haven't been able to before.
Imagine taking $100
and turning that into $1,000.
I see a stock going up and I buy it
and I just watch it
until it stops going up
and then I sell it.
Let's see this one keep on falling, 1.57,
let's keep it going on down, baby.
We're cracking trend lines
and let's just lock it on up, baby.
Let's just lock it on up
and take $50,000 in a day!
Let's go!
It was really a wake up call
to a new kind of investor
and a kind of investor
that, in many cases, was using
Robinhood to place trades
and trade, not based on
fundamentals necessarily,
but based on something
that seemed like fun.
While Robinhood isn't the only app
that's design and usability
blurs the lines between investing,
entertainment and gambling,
it's left many people asking,
is this product a little
too good at what it does?
There's something to learn
between the old world and the new world.
The new world is much more frictionless,
giving a lot more access to everyone else.
So, I think that change is happening
and a lot of the old world applications
are still not understanding
what it takes, to be honest.
So, we're just in a
completely uncharted territory
in some ways.
This is a new type of behavior
that's emerged in the past year.
Like, meme stock was not
in the vernacular in 2020,
is all I'm saying.
During the pandemic through 2020,
we saw that app usage grew on average 40%.
There were about 35 billion downloads.
What we found is that,
whilst users have a lot
of apps on their phone.
So, typically 80 or so
apps on their phone.
Less than half of them are
used on a monthly basis.
And so now, it's not just
about creating an app,
it's about making sure that
you get a user to download it,
making sure that the app's sticky enough
that they come back on
your daily active users
or your weekly active users.
Those numbers are also high.
The pandemic offered an opportunity
for older apps that had
plateaued in user growth.
As people delved deeper
into the app store,
the products that proved most appealing
were the ones that offered
something more long
lasting to their users,
be it a language, a new skill or money.
So, as soon as the
coronavirus pandemic hit,
what happened was a lot of people
started spending a lot of time at home
and that boredom really led to them
trying to find out new things to do
and the interest in
investing really peaked
in the middle of the pandemic
because people were at home
and they had access to their phones.
And for the first time,
Robinhood became an app
of massive interest.
It's been around since early 2010s,
but it really didn't go off the way it did
until the pandemic hit.
There's no question that Robinhood
has been wildly popular
in attracting users.
You've got more than
22 million active users
on the platform now
and that's just in a
matter of a couple of years
that they've built that base.
The platform opened up
to investors in 2015.
So, the growth that they've
seen has been astronomical.
So, I think what you need to understand
when you're trying to understand
why the Robinhood user
experience is that good
is who built it.
And we're talking about the
co-founders of Robinhood here,
Vlad Tenev and Baiju Bhatt.
These were two guys who met at Stanford
at a time when Facebook,
Twitter, Instagram,
all of those apps were really taking off
and had really established what it means
to be an application that
drives user engagement
and really draws people in.
Think about pop-up notifications
or the ability to engage
with your friends.
So, if you invite a
friend to the platform,
you get a free stock.
All of those things hadn't
really existed before
and so, they really pioneered the way
for investing to become
way more democratized
through a very social
media like experience.
So, I'm opening my Robinhood app
and I see a nice little green screen
with the feather logo in the back
and what comes up is this
very clean interface.
You don't have to type anything
into your phone, right?
So, you get lists of things
that you can just scroll up or down
to click the correct answer.
And I know it's really trivial, right?
Like, you can just type in New York
rather than having to
scroll up and pick New York,
but those are sort of the design features
that, when you talk to experts, will say,
it's just easier, right?
You don't have to type anything in.
They would tell you that
that is just, again,
sort of bringing down barriers
and making it easier for people,
from a design point of view,
to sort of sign up.
A critical element for Robinhood
is making that first trade for these users
as easy as possible.
When signing up to most brokerages,
a user will have to wait a few days
before money is deposited
into their account
and they can start trading.
But Robinhood lets users
trade up to a thousand dollars instantly
while waiting for their account to clear.
If I were a first-time investor,
I would not find anything
intimidating about this.
It's kind of welcoming, honestly.
Right up front,
there's a big button to click trade,
I can see the volume
and I have the option
to either buy shares of, let's say, Apple
or trade options on it if I want,
that's right there for me too.
And so, really what you
see in the Robinhood app
is just very little information
presented in a very user-friendly way
with a lot of colors,
with a lot of animation,
and that's something that
hadn't really existed
in brokerage platforms before.
From data font sizes
that help direct users
to what they should focus on
to the snowflake animation
that falls on December 25th,
Robinhood has been very deliberate
in all its design choices.
Take the cryptocurrency
trading page for example,
its interface reflects the excitement
and buzz around this type of investing.
It almost looks like
you're in like a video game
or an ad for like an
energy drink or something.
It's a design element
that's completely different
from anything that I've seen
on a traditional trading platform.
There's a lot of these
delightful graphical moments
where it's just reflective
of almost an artist signing their work.
You've gone from 15 years ago,
people seeing folks sitting
with six or seven screens and trading
to realizing actually
you've got your mobile phone
and a small screen
and you can achieve
the same outcome really
as an individual.
Those trading systems, the data,
the exchanges, the trading exchanges,
they've been the same for years and years.
What's changed is there
is now a user interface
that makes it easily accessible
to a broader set of users.
We're proud of the fact
that we've enabled so
many younger investors
and first time investors to
have access to the markets.
I think design is at the heart of it
because the ease of use,
the enjoyment that a user
gets using the application
is so important.
Over half of Robinhood uses
are first-time investors,
with 70% of its assets held
by millennial investors
between 18 and 40.
It's popularity among young
investors has been in part
down to a frictionless user experience.
Friction refers to something in the design
that slows you down in
accomplishing your goal.
This may sound familiar
if you've ever tried to
unsubscribe from a mailing list
and being presented with
something like this.
One of the things that
people talk a lot about
is frictionless user experience.
Designers, more and more, are realizing
that users are unforgiving.
They will drop off during the registration
or sign-up process.
They will drop off if
they get stuck on a screen
and can't work out what
the next call to action is.
Designers are now starting
to value user feedback,
look at what users are doing
in terms of using an app.
So, tracking through heat maps, etc,
what kind of utilization the app has
from a user perspective.
If you look back at how Robinhood
really sort of created
this user interface,
was by going out to coffee stands
and coffee shops at Stanford
and going up to students and asking them
how they felt about investing
and how they felt about the
apps that were out there
and really getting the
sort of feedback from users
about what they wanted to see
and what they didn't want to see.
And even up until this day,
Robinhood research team
is really, really prevalent in the company
and they really go out of their way
to sort of try to give
users what they want,
but there's cost to that.
While frictionless user experience
may be what customers want,
some argue the frictions
in investment apps
can actually work as a safety mechanism.
The problem for many investors
with making trading too easy
is that oftentimes frictions
take the place of self-control.
And when something is too easy,
we may do it more than is
in our own best interests.
So, I've done research
over the last few decades
that showed that, on average,
when individual investors
trades more actively,
they end up worse off.
There's not a great deal
of information on the app
compared to other brokerage sites.
And one thing that does
is gives one the feeling
that this is not too complicated
of a thing to do, to
buy and sell stocks.
And clearly, the mechanics of
buying and selling are easy,
but choosing stocks,
analyzing stocks can be difficult.
We put a great value in this country,
in letting people have the
freedom to do what they want
and yet, we also want to
have some protections.
The family of 20 year-old Alex Kearns
is suing popular stock
trading app, Robinhood,
after Kearns died by suicide last year,
believing he was hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt.
The worst aspect of what they do, Chloe,
is the way they're gamifying
the idea of investing.
They're taking unsophisticated investors,
most of whom have no experience,
and basically making this into a game,
causing them to suffer losses.
Robinhood has faced some
pretty serious criticism
that it's making investing almost too fun,
which seems like a strange criticism.
But the point is that
they've made investing
so accessible and so easy
that they might be pushing traders
to take risks that they don't understand
or outsize risks in financial markets
or see stock trading as kind of a game
or kind of a gamble.
And for the critics of Robinhood,
there's one design element
that never fails to get mentioned.
I'm a bit surprised by how much attention
the confetti animation has gotten.
It's literally an animation that comes up
after you make your first trade.
You think, from reading
some of the commentary,
that confetti's flying through
the app all over the place.
The story behind the confetti
is that Robinhood used to
display a confetti graphic
to celebrate the first trade
that you made on the platform.
And the confetti motif also came up
in its ad campaigns early on,
where you would see people
trading on their Robinhood app.
With an app that's changing
the way we do money.
Now, what came to pass
was confetti became like the
thing people would point to
when they said Robinhood
is gamifying investing.
Eventually, Robinhood scrapped
the confetti graphic altogether,
but it's not like you're going to see
people migrate away from Robinhood
just because they don't
show confetti anymore
when you place your first trade.
In my mind, gamification is so broad.
It's anything that allows you
to almost experiment
and enjoy the process.
The fear that a lot of regulators have
is that retail investors
don't have the knowledge base
that professional investors have
and as a result of
things like gamification
or stickiness in an app,
they'll almost be brainwashed into
or influenced into making
investments or taking risks
that they otherwise would
not be comfortable doing.
But I actually don't
think that's the case.
I think users are going
on to apps, etc,
because they want to invest.
They want to try investing
in different securities
that otherwise they didn't have access to.
And there was a particular stock
that really captured the
imagination of these new investors.
In January this year,
users of Robinhood and other trading apps
pushed up the price of GameStop options,
leaving hedge funds
facing hundreds of millions
of dollars in losses.
Let's start off with
what is almost bordering
on the ridiculousness here
with regards to the GameStop trade.
Do you see a fundamental reordering here
in the hierarchy of who has
the power on Wall Street?
A platform like Robinhood
was the perfect sort of vehicle
to create this frenzy in trading
because it made it so easy
that now so many people
had access to this stock
and it took off.
Of course, what we've
all been talking about,
a stock which has now
been on a rocket ship
as part of this short squeeze
and whether those that
are investing in this
fully understand what
they're investing in.
Robinhood customers
with all of their traits
like younger,
maybe more plugged in to
online message boards,
maybe with a little bit
less than their account
and more of an appetite
for YOLO-type investing,
this all came to a head
in the GameStop saga
and it was the first time
that we'd really seen
such a mass coordination
of retail investors online.
In the wake of GameStop,
Robinhood's CEO, Vlad Tenev,
testified before Congress.
He was questioned on a variety of topics,
including his decision to halt
customers buying these stocks
and faced scrutiny over the app's design.
Confetti falls every
time they place an order,
they get push notifications,
they're encouraged to trade.
If a friend signs up, they
get a free stock, on and on.
Why have you added specific
gaming design elements
to look like gambling to your app?
There was also criticism
of the way Robinhood makes its money.
Instead of taking a slice from the user,
Robinhood takes its cut
by selling customers
orders to trading firms.
Put simply, the more a user trades,
the more money Robinhood makes,
leaving some to question
whether the apps frictionless
user-friendly design
was actually in its user's best interest.
In 2020, Robinhood earned
about 75% of its revenue
based on transactions
happening on the platform.
So, that gives its
critics ammunition to say
Robinhood wants you to trade more,
whether or not it's good
for your financial health
to be buying and selling
stocks all day or all week.
Robinhood is there making
money from transactions
and at present, without
that source of revenue,
I mean,
it would lose three quarters
of its business, basically.
Now, the U.S. Security
and Exchange Commission
is weighing whether to ban
this way of doing business.
Robinhood's legal chief,
who himself is a former SEC commissioner,
said banning payment for
order flow would be "draconian".
What you're going to see moving forward
is a lot more regulatory scrutiny
and a lot more regulation
to set in place some
protections for these investors.
But I don't think it's
going to happen quickly.
I think it's going to take time
and in the meantime,
having access to these financial tools
is going to go one of two ways.
It's either going to help people
learn more about the stock market
or it's going to help
them lose a lot of money.
I think it would be completely crazy
to almost penalize someone
for building a high quality,
high functioning well-designed app.
Innovation is inherently
fraught with risk.
Of course, the utility they
offer can be regulated,
but the fact that they make
it easy for users to use
and make it fun for users to use
has to fall outside that
regulatory set of restrictions.
I think that's something that,
if you start regulating that,
you're stifling innovation.